MAN GAME-WORN JERSEY.
>> YES, SIR.
GAME WORN JERSEY.
>> Johnny: LIVE FOR IT.
EARLY THEY ARE SEASON IN
JANUARY, AT GOLDEN STATE YOU
COMPLETED THE NBA ARENA TOUR.
YOU HAVE BEEN EVERYWHERE, HOW
WAS IT?
>> IT WAS AMAZING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
LIKE TO SEE THE PISTONS PLAY IN
EVERY SINGLE NBA ARENA, PLUS LAS
VEGAS, PLUS MEXICO CITY A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO, UNREAL.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE TIME.
>> Johnny: WHEN DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
>> WHEN I WAS A KID IT WAS
SOMETHING I DREAMT OF DOING,
AND, YOU KNOW, A FEW YEARS AGO I
JUST WENT TO MILWAUKEE AND
CHICAGO AND INDIANA AND IT JUST
SORT OF SPIRALED FROM THERE.
YEAH.
>> Johnny: SO YOU ARE A PISTONS
SEASON TICKET HOLDER TODAY THEY
HOOKED UP UP YOU ARE SITTING
COURTSIDE BIG TIME.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE.
LIFELONG DREAM TO SIT COURTSIDE.
I AM IN DISBELIEF I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT HAPPENED.
>> Johnny: NOW WE JUST PULLED
YOU AWAY FROM THE COURTSIDE
SEEDS TO TALK TO ME.
LET'S GET BACK TO IT, BRO.
>> THROUGH, BROTHER.
>> Johnny: CORY.
>> Johnny: ORIGINAL, WILL YOU
JOIN KNEE IN TOPPING OUR HAT TO
THAT FAN,.
>> George: I AM PROUD OF YOU, WE
MEETER YOUR SUPPORT.
YOUR LOYALTY, SEEMS LIKE A GREAT
GUY.
>> Greg: YEAH, THAT'S AWESOME.